monsieur bigot merci d'être avec nous
bienvenu j'aime le dire 10e journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui on le sait les
cortèges s'amenuisent ya beaucoup moins
de gens en grève on le voit comment
continuer à faire pression justement sur
ce gouvernement qui semble ne rien
vouloir entendre avec parallèlement un
recul de la participation aux
manifestations et à la grève bonjour oui
effectivement c'est une situation qui
est un peu délicate à l'heure actuelle
la médiatisation aussi elle baisse 1
même si on voit qu'il continue à y avoir
une attention elle a quand même
nettement baissé par rapport à des jt
qui était focalisé là dessus de la
plupart des chaînes aujourd'hui on voit
que cette attention à la bc et les
médias c'est quand même un élément
essentiel pour capter l'opinion pour
avoir l'opinion de son côté et puis
aussi pour arriver à capter l'attention
du grand public
après pour la mobilisation elle essaye
de changer donc déjà on n'a plus une
grève en continu on a des petites
journées comme ça qu'ils interviennent
de temps en temps et puis on a également
des coups de poing comme le font bien
les avocats il se met en scène
soit ils ne viennent pas et bien au
tribunal soit au contraire ils viennent
en masse au tribunal on avait des procès
où il venait à 10 pour défendre une
seule personne ou alors il fondé des
actions coup de poing comme ils l'ont
fait à plusieurs reprises en jetant
leurs robes
on a vu aussi ce type d'actions coup de
poing avec l'opéra avec les musiciens de
l'opéra qui à plusieurs reprises ont
également et bien fait des concerts sur
le parvis de l'opéra alors la
mobilisation contre cette réforme des
retraites a battu le record de durée du
conflit social a en 1995 mais sans pour
autant obtenir le report
du retrait du texte est ce que ce
mouvement il est pas en train de marquer
a définitivement la perte d' influence
des syndicats ou au contraire c'est
compliqué parce que évidemment en 95 des
syndicats était quand même plus fort il
y avait plus de monde qui étaient
syndiqués
ça n'a cessé de diminuer depuis par
ailleurs il était aussi plus unis alors
que là il ya clairement des divisions
entre les différents syndicats et par
ailleurs à l'époque ça avait été une
grève qui avait été très longue alors
celle-ci a battu le record mais celle ci
a été sans doute aussi - continue konan
a été la grève de 1995 qui était
beaucoup plus dur et enfin le dernier
élément c'est que la société autour a
changé aussi
dans 95 c'était un véritable blocage
quasi totale on a revu des images à
propos de cette grève
mais par exemple pour faire un trajet
banlieue à paris ou même à l'intérieur
de paris
eh bien vous n'aviez comme choix que de
faire du stop ou de trouver un autre
moyen c'est-à-dire un taxi par exemple
aujourd'hui vous avez quand même une
diversité de moyens que les français ont
d'ailleurs largement utilisés pour
justement éviter de subir la grève vous
parliez à l'instant de de ces syndicats
qui sont pas forcément unis au sein même
de cette manifestation
est ce que jean rtement justement leur
désunion elle ne freine pas un peu
l'ampleur du mouvement
oui complètement alors les syndicats ça
fait longtemps qu'ils sont désunis ce
sont des lignes de fracture qui sont
très anciennes
pour certains qui remonte au début du
20e siècle pour d'autres qui remonte au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
donc ces fractures elles sont vraiment
ancienne et profonde
sauf que à chaque fois qu'ils ont réussi
à faire l'unité ça a été le cas en 36
évidemment avec le front populaire c'est
elle qui à 68 c'était le cas en 95 ils
ont réussi et bien impactées et a obligé
le gouvernement à céder là leur désunion
clairement et bien ne va pas en faveur
du mouvement social on parle beaucoup du
49-3 parce que le texte est actuellement
examiné à l'assemblée nationale
est-ce que ce spectre qui plane un peu
est ce que vous y croyez est-ce que le
gouvernement va avoir recours aux 49 3 à
voir il aurait rocco cards off 3
pourquoi parce que
évidemment le débat semble long avec
tous les amendements dont on a dont on a
parlé mais en soi contrairement aux
précédents gouvernements qu'ils
pouvaient avoir des craintes d'une
véritable fronde interne au sein du
parti socialiste
là le gouvernement il a quand même une
majorité qui est forte certes il ya eu
quelques départs seria quelques
personnes quelques députés de la
majorité qui ont fait entendre leur voix
mais il reste quand même mineur la
plupart du parti est très soudée
derrière là derrière la réforme donc ce
49,3 ça serait juste pour accélérer le
processus
en quelque sorte donc c'est possible
qu'ils soient utilisés de toute façon
aujourd'hui un petit peu entré dans les
moeurs 1 on a vu que manuel valls en
avait fait une très large utilisation
moi même j'ai travaillé sur un
spécialiste du 49-3 donc michel rocard
mais dans les circonstances qui était
quand même différente n'avait lui qu'une
majorité relative n'est pas de majorité
absolue
c'est pour ça qu'il a beaucoup utilisé
le 49-3 c'est ce qu'a ramené trois
aujourd'hui un peu entré dans les moeurs
l'opinion publique sait bien que ça fait
partie et bien du répertoire d'action
des gouvernants donc ils continuent sans
doute un petit peu de choqué parce que
ça fait taire et ça prive un peu le
parlement de sa voix mais en soi ça
n'accélérera pas la contestation sociale
et ça ne fera pas taire non plus le
parlement merci pierre emmanuel guigou
je rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences en histoire à l'université
paris est créteil et auteur du livre
michel rocard aux éditions perrin merci
merci à vous